folks
listen i i had a bad week and i've had
it with the biden administration i'm
done my goose is cooked here joe biden
is a disgrace to humankind he is he's
completely turned his back on the
disastrous crisis on our southern border
and because of that he is a direct
accomplice to the mass murder of
thousands of american citizens listen i
use my words carefully and very
deliberately and i mean every single
word of that
before you say hey slow down
let's take a look at the definition of
the word accomplice according to
merriam-webster and accomplices quote
one associated with another especially
in wrongdoing keep that in your head as
i go through the rest of this year it's
a fact
our kids are being intentionally killed
and poisoned intentionally using
fentanyl brought in through the border
by drug cartels in mexico and it
originates with the chinese communist
party the chemicals for the fed now
listen the stats don't lie folks they
don't lie u.s overdose deaths
in the year ending in february of 2022
surged nearly 20 percent
in just one year
and the number is going up it's not
going down
but what happens when thousands of these
same migrants are put on buses at the
border and sent to blue cities like
washington d.c suddenly it's a crisis so
overwhelming
the democrats demand federal
intervention
we need space
and we we need the federal government to
be involved so i've asked for the
deployment of the guard as long as we
need the guard to deal with the
humanitarian crisis
that we expect to escalate the number of
people crossing the border seeking
asylum
we expect to only go up
so
your kids are dead from fentanyl no
problem illegal immigrants in my city
big big problem
but they still aren't interested in
securing the border which would solve
remember the root causes of the problem
kamala's always looking for a root cause
well there it is the border instead
democrats just want red states to bail
them out while accusing conservatives
conservatives are playing politics
so the white house's preference would be
for small towns in texas and arizona to
have to take care of these migrants
rather than a large metropolitan that's
not what i said washington that is not
what i said
yeah they are they're sending migrants
to big cities on purpose using them as a
political point
it's not just the migrants the drugs
brought in by the cartels are poisoning
thousands of americans oh but dan you
know fentanyl that's a border town
border state problem no no no no no
think again
fentanyl overdose deaths are
skyrocketing in cities like nashville
denver and chicago you know we picked
these stories on the screen you're
reading in these headlines for a reason
what do they have in common
they aren't anywhere near our southern
border
because it's not a border state problem
this crisis is in every american city as
i said biden is an accomplice to mass
murder don't doubt me
the left is intentionally allowing this
to happen at the border here's a few
ways they're doing it right now from fox
quote
ice developing a program to give id
cards to illegal immigrants as border
crisis rages does anyone with
functioning neurons in their cranial
cavity have an issue with that i mean
i'm asking seriously as i said
joe biden's white house they're
accomplices to this
last week we had tom homan
on to talk about how the democrats want
to allow asylum applications online like
you're buying like a movie ticket
so migrants can just hop on a plane from
anywhere in the world and claim asylum
at an airport and don't forget the
administration has been trying for
months to get rid of title 42 code
enforcement rules after getting rid of
trump's remain in mexico policy
folks if joe biden knows the drugs are
flowing in via the cartels which he does
and is doing nothing to stop it but
instead is trying to actually accelerate
the problem then i will say it again and
i will mean it again he is an accomplice
to the mass murder of thousands of
americans
senator cruz said it best when he went
to the border
joe biden and kamala harris are
responsible
for the worst plague of slavery in
america
since the civil war
you still not convinced you don't think
the administrations that accomplished
this mass murder
listen to what the parents of a child
who died from accidental fentanyl
overdoses this is what they have to say
about it
how does a vibrant healthy physically
capable 17 year old just no longer lives
chris just said
our baby is gone the groups that i'm a
part of are thousands strong
uh you know there's more being added
every single day it's it's
it's disgusting how many how many people
are dying he was just an innocent kid
he made one dumbness decision and he
died
it's hard to watch isn't it
a lot of you parents out there too one
mistake
i made a lot of dumb mistakes in my life
they didn't deserve to die for it
instead of doing their jobs by the way
that they were elected to do this
disgraceful administration has the nerve
to spit in their faces and lie to us as
our children are dying listen to them
telling you don't worry the border's
secure
the border is
secure
the border
we are working to make the border more
secure the border is closed the border
is secure
i can only hope this buffoon is
impeached the
second they take back the house
and remember when our esteemed borders
are kabula harris took months to just
visit the border and then did jack squat
to fix it
you know i know what you're going to say
you're going to say uh dan bargino what
are you saying illegal immigrants are
all murderers no that's not what i said
that's what you said what i'm saying is
that the biden administration is
allowing mass migration illegal mass
migration that sucks up the attention
and resources of our border agents which
the cartels take advantage of in the
chinese communist party to traffic drugs
and migrants with little resistance sex
trafficked kids too
someone who's an accomplice has no
intentions to stop a crime and biden's
case actually facilitates it so how can
he fix it well it's pretty easy you know
joe biden could start by supporting our
border agents instead of accusing them
of whipping people
how about biden announced that every
single drug trafficker will be thrown in
jail or rep or deported but he will do
none of that
zero
why
because as i said he is an accomplice to
the mass murder of american citizens
that starts at our southern border hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else